those who make the worst use of their
time
are the first to complain
of its brevity
[Music]
two persons cannot long be friends if
they cannot forgive each other's little
failings
life is a tragedy for those who feel
and a comedy for those who think
the pleasure of criticizing takes away
from us the pleasure of being moved by
some very fine things
such a great misfortune
not to be able to be alone
there are only three events in a man's
life
birth
life and death
he is not conscious of being born
he dies in pain
and he forgets to live
the most exquisite pleasure
is giving pleasure to others
sudden love takes the longest time to be
cured
[Music]
the unnamed should not be mistaken for
the non-existent
out of difficulties
grow miracles
[Music]
if some persons died and others did not
die
death would indeed be a terrible
affliction
if poverty is the mother of all crimes
lack of intelligence is their father
evil people are like flies that crawl
over the human body
and stop only at its ulcers
one seeks to make the loved one entirely
happy
or
if that cannot be
entirely wretched
when a woman does not take her eyes off
a man
or all the time takes them away from him
everyone immediately understands what it
means
generosity
lies less in giving much
than in giving at the right moment
time
which strengthens friendship
weakens love
[Music]
the pleasure of criticism takes away
from us the pleasure of being deeply
moved
by very fine things
we are afraid of the old age
which we may never attain
grief in the absence of a loved one
is happiness compared to life with a
person one hates
a man is rich whose income is larger
than his expenses
and he is poor if his expenses are
greater than his income
a person's worth in this world
is estimated according to the value they
put on themselves
as favor and riches forsake a man
we discover in him the foolishness they
concealed
and which no one perceived before
all of our unhappiness
comes from our inability to be alone
[Music]
men are willing to be slaves in one
place
if they can only lord it in another
trying to forget someone means
remembering him all the time
what a pity that we don't live long
enough to benefit from the lessons
of our mistakes
the disclosure of a secret is always
guilty of the one who entrusted it to
another
we love to criticize so much
that we lose the ability to deeply feel
a truly beautiful creation
[Music]
even beautiful ceases to be beautiful
when it is out of place
the woman everyone thinks is cold
simply hasn't met a person who would
awaken love in her yet
it is not natural for a person to love
others more than himself
anyone who loves work does not need
entertainment
people value too little an opportunity
to bring joy to their neighbors
to laugh at men of sense
is the privilege of fools
the trouble is
when a person does not have enough
intelligence to say well or common sense
to carefully keep silent
a real man doesn't have time to cheat
because that man is too busy providing
all of which a good woman deserves
[Music]
a man is very stupid
if he doesn't tell his wife compliments
people rarely respect someone who can
make them laugh
[Music]